first of all,
grammar and spelling.
that's the first thing you need to learn.
secondly, I know what the fuck I'm talking about.
definition of nationality.
the status of belonging to a particular nation.
definition of race.
a concept used to describe a group of people
who share physical characteristics
such as skin color and facial features.
definition of ethnicity.
the quality or fact of belonging to a population,
group, or subgroup made up of people who share a common
cultural background or descent.
see the difference between me and you, moron?
I know how to use Google,
and I understand words.
you know, the words that you tried to put together
that barely.
I could barely understand.
again, grammar is important.
spelling is important.
and maybe learn how to look up words in a dictionary.
don't come for me,
because I'm gonna make you look stupid
every single time.
you think I'm gonna know it all?
good. the fuck
out of here.